reg wanted to call in and talk about
Charles Oakley who got booted line he
got arrested last night at Madison
Square Garden so oak the former enforcer
for the Knicks spent ten years there and
he got arrested last night during the
game and Reggie Miller joining us on the
program reg good morning what do you
have for me well well good morning
gentlemen and I look I can't blame
tyronn lue for resting his big three
remember in Washington that unbelievable
overtime victory LeBron James Bing
facade to send it to overtime and then
they end up winning with Kyrie Irving
you know going off in the overtime when
LeBron is fouled out last night in
Indiana they were down 15 and then a
4218 run in that third quarter pulled
away from Indiana so I could see them
being tired for tonight is it great for
our network to have those three guys
sitting tonight no it's not you would
like to see you know those guys go
against Russell Westbrook but I it's
probably going to happen you think
they're going to all three [ __ ] well if
he's already mentioning it yeah and yeah
he's you know laying the groundwork that
he's going to sit I would probably say
two of the three with it could I rien
probably LeBron but Reggie if you were
playing now or you know Jordan or magic
or bird [ __ ] just to be fair to today's
stars you know they take care of their
their careers they paced themselves a
little bit differently do you think
yesterday's stars would do the same
thing with Jordan pace himself
differently it's funny I never thought
of it I never thought of sitting out I
never you played the game if you were
healthy enough to play you played rather
you play greater you didn't you still
played I always felt even if I was tired
or even when I was hurt if I had a you
know her ankle or something like that I
always felt me at seventy-five percent
80 was better than a lot of people I was
still out there to help my team out so
you just played but it's a little bit
different now I think you know
Commissioner silver will they'll address
this in the offseason and
you know we'll go from there but it'd be
nice to have all three of them play
tonight but I don't think it's going to
happen all right what did you see last
night with Charles Oakley and I know
there's bad blood because oak has not
been embraced by the Knicks organization
he bought his own ticket to the game but
you get arrested at the garden now look
we know the Knicks side of it that he
was being belligerent he was yelling at
james dolan and he was causing a scene
for the fans where he was city that's
the next position now we've heard from
Charles Oakley who said look I was there
only four minutes I came i sat down i
was there to watch the game and the
scene really didn't start until james
dolan look back in solving our city
behind him and asked security to escort
me out that's when I started to get loud
and started to yell so the truth lies in
between I'm going to tell you I have not
spoken to oak I don't know what happened
but to me this is probably what happened
as you mentioned he's been asked to stay
away from the team this is the seven
70th anniversary of the Knicks
organization and he's not around for
those glory teams of the 90s that I've
had so many battles with he's been asked
to stay away and he's probably heard
about that his good friend Patrick Ewing
probably didn't get an interview to be
the head coaching job for the New York
Knicks he keeps getting skipped over so
oakley kabhi said you know what okay i'm
going to buy these tickets or was given
to him that's what I'm hearing too but
so what right behind James Dolan and he
was probably hoping that Dolan would
turn around and see him and extended
olive olive branches say hey oak this is
it all for too long come to my office
tomorrow let's hash this out and this
pump is over I'm sure that's what Oakley
was probably thinking when he turned
around and saw that it was Charles
Oakley and then had all his guys
security who this is the problem do you
think Charles Oakley is going to show up
in a nice-looking suit to start some
beef if he would have came in jeans and
some timberlands and jeans perhaps
hopefully was suited down do you think
he's coming there
her to be an idiot on national TV that's
this is my opinion yeah I just think he
was looking for an olive ranch to be
extended when it was it look the
security he put these security guards in
a very uncomfortable position because
these are the safe look I know all the
security guards you guys were here when
I played I sweated my heart out for all
of you guys and this is how I'm going to
be treated I think that's why he went
off on the list of guys you would not
mess with when you played where does
Oakley rank on that list well I said
this before on this show there's a dark
alley is that people you want to walk
down with some people are the dark alley
internal guys that are the dark alley
and here's another thing that's like I'm
trying to be partial here but I know
this is everywhere in its leading sports
center and all that yeah that's great
and all but stopped showing the clip of
Charles Oakley always getting in fights
and being the Intimidator yes that was
him but we're feeding into oh my god he
must have a short temper this is unknown
Charles over 25 years and yes he's
taking me out of the out of the air
probably half a dozen times but he was a
competitor and stop showing clips of him
always wanting to fight because we're
feed into him trying to be a thug and
being an Intimidator which he was and
that was his description but why are we
always feeding into why can't we show a
clip of him of a basketball play now
it's fair reg and I do appreciate you
calling in and given another side to
this and hopefully you get a good game
tonight you got the calves and the
Thunder on TNT so uh thanks for joining
us reg I appreciated gentleman thanks
for having me I Reggie Miller giving us
a little different perspective and look
I respect the fact that Reggie wasn't
supposed to join us and was watching the
show and said let me give my my side to
this because there is another side to
this I don't know what else happens with
us I thought the Knicks were really
unprofessional when they sent out a
message saying we hope Charles Oakley
gets help that is that is
excusable inexcusable to say that you
hope like he's got some condition that
you're diagnosing here and even if there
is a condition he has you don't do that
publicly something made this happen that
it went from zero to 60 and I'm not
going to put all this on Charles Oakley
not the dan patrick show weekday morning
on audience
[Music]